a coder I admire in named Dora keeps
using compiler Explorer
she's much cooler than me but I think I
can be quite as cool if I just learn
assembler so whose assembly knowledge is
as bad as that's Limerick or worse okay
most of you good my assembly knowledge
is about at that level but that's fine
in order to use compiler Explorer you
don't need to be an assembly expert so
my name is onyx Newton and welcome to
just enough assembly for compiler
Explorer this is very much of absolute
beginners introduction to assembly and
x86 64 : convention so if you know a bit
of assembly from before there's probably
not much new so there's still time to
escape who has used compiler Explorer
before also known as got both after its
creator Matt yeah quite a few who has
seen it used in conference talks or like
your new Tube videos or stuff like that
quite a few of you as well so I saw on
Twitter a few weeks ago that Jason
Turner have a little Twitter poll saying
are you planning to use compiler
Explorer in your upcoming C purpose
related presentation or did you use it
recently in a presentation and the
options were no yes not presenting or
just show results and you can see all
the people who are presenting more than
half say they're going to use compiler
Explorer so this is not very
unscientific right it's very prone to
selection bias is tagging compiler story
there but it shows that there is quite a
lot of interest in compiler story these
days so what's good about compiler
Explorer you can take your C simple plus
or rust or some other languages as well
paste it on the website and you can see
the assembly outputs from the compiler
now why is that interesting it's
interesting because you write your C and
C++ code or other languages as well for
all
humans to read and then the compiler
translated to the cpu and it turns out
that the CPU instructions that the
compiler will give the CPU they
correspond to assembly instructions so
if you can see assembly instructions
you know what the compiler did your code
what is it going to feed the CPU what's
also nice is that you don't only see one
compiler you can have several compiler
so you can compare clang to GCC to MSV C
and you can put in different options so
you can say ok what happens on a one on
oh oh oh three etc so it's really quite
flexible so let's just start with having
a look here and that's probably way too
small so yeah here's just a bunch of
assembly code and some C code and I'm
not going to read through it right now
what's what's interesting is here you
can paste your code and then you see the
assembly output and you can see that's
okay so here's a function called
computer well here is the assembly code
from that function and if I scroll down
I can see here's the assembly code for
the caller function Silicon tokens and
you can see also if I hover it will
highlight the lines of code that the
assembly came from and the other way
around and it's color coded it and it's
trying to be really helpful to allow you
to correlate your code with the assembly
output there's a lot of stuff here on
the right but in 50 minutes you can are
going to understand every line to the
right here and I'm actually not going to
go fast either so still going to go
quite slowly but still you'll be able to
understand why it's doing all of these
things so let's not read through all of
it but let's look at okay there are some
things that seem to be going on a lot so
this D word patters seem to be important
and you can see EDI and ESI is used here
both in computer and down in color and
it's pushing and popping rbp yeah so
lots of stuff going on and let's
let's learn what all of this is about so
for today's talk it's mostly going to be
stepping through assembly in a toy
debugger in a like a toy slide where
emulator so before I start if there are
any questions please ask the questions
while the code is up here so don't wait
until the end it's better to because
we're gonna have a lot of code on the
slides so ask while the code is there so
in my little toy assembly x86 emulator
in the middle of the screen is the CPU
and the CPU has a bunch of registers we
are we have some special registers some
general-purpose that we can use for
whatever we want and in order for the
computer to do anything interesting with
data it needs to get data into those
registers so that's going to be our main
focus and we're only for each example
going to show the relevant register so
if you have an example using only these
are the I and our si registers well only
going to show those do not just blow the
slides and we're going to initialize
them to 0 for each example that doesn't
happen in reality it just makes the
examples easier to follow and show
everything in hex so let's get some
assembly code up so here's our first
assembly program for today it has three
lines of code and each line has an
instruction to the left and 0 or more
operands to the right and I put a little
indicator what's this doing No thank you
ok put a little indicator so we can step
debug through the code like this right
just like in a normal normal debugger
and yeah so let's start with the first
instruction it's a move instruction and
just like in C++ move doesn't move in
assembly it means copy so it's going to
copy one of these operands into the
other one and in this case it's actually
going to copy the second operand into
the first and that's because we're using
into assembly syntax to our other
syntaxes for assembly
in tow maybe feels a bit backwards
because it says move RTI - that means
move - into RDI there are other syntaxes
that are the other way around but I
think Intel is the most readable one in
other respects it's the default one on
compiler Explorer and I think it's the
one that people tend to prefer prefer
these days so the first instruction is a
move instruction it's asks us to move to
into our DOI and when we execute that we
can see we got the value - into the
register called RDI then we move for
into RSI and then there's the add the
instruction I guess you can guess what
the add instruction does it adds its
operands together and we are used to in
our high-level languages saying like
results or int result equal a plus B in
assembly the result goes in the first
operand so it's more like RTI plus
equals RSI so if we execute that line it
will add together the 204 and put 6 the
result in first operand RDI I don't know
about those names like many of the
registers have some meaningful names
yeah they have some very common usages
this day but I'm not sure actually about
their names remember I'm not very much
better than the limericks oh no that's
not too tricky questions okay so that
was registers we also need to use memory
right we have 16 general-purpose
64-bit registers not much you can do
with that so we need some memory as well
so I put some memory on the right-hand
side here as well so these are memory
addresses they're actually 64 bit long
but I don't want to blow the slides so
let's just show the last two bytes
and here's the value at that address in
memory and today we're going to focus
mainly on the stack but everything about
addressing memory on the stack that I
show today is going to be exactly the
same if you want to address some other
memory it's the same things but we use
the stack mostly today so on this
architecture the stack grows downwards
so our stack is like coming from up here
and it's growing down here and there's a
new register RSP that's the stack
pointer that has a very good name I
guess so we have a RS piece it's like
pointer it happens to currently point to
be zero in memory so I put a little
pointer here as well RSP is pointing
here so this is top the top of the stack
but that's the stack is growing
downwards the top of the stack when you
push stuff on the tach stack the top is
going to go down like this so it's a bit
that's a might be a bit confusing so
yeah let's first put value in our
register so let's just put this little
value here and immediate value or put it
into our di and I just picked this
number because it's very easy to see the
difference bytes and see where they end
up at the end now then we're going to
push what are we going to push we're
going to push our di on the stack so
when we push a register we're going to
copy the contents of the register onto
the stack and then bump the stack
pointer so we're on x86 64 64-bit
registers so how many bytes are we going
to push on the stack and increments a
counter with eight bytes eight bytes 64
bits and the second question is okay
where are we going to end up RSP is up
here and we're gonna subtract actually
since it grows downwards subtract eight
we get get down to a eight and what's
the value of that byte going to be
there's one correct answer and there's
one wrong but closeable answer and the
rest are just plain wrong
yeah so those are both yeah so the eight
8086 has a little endian architecture so
that means when you design a CPU you
have to like decide on which parts go
where so a little endian architecture
means the least significant particles on
the lowest memory address so if we
execute this line you can see it bumped
our HP down here and put the number in
on other architectures there on the
answer could be f e because there's no
reason why it has to be in a certain
order in memory but that's how our
architecture is yeah then we can pop so
I skipped ahead a little bit away we can
also pop we pushed our D I so now I have
these bytes in here and then we can pop
them into another register so now we
have problems of the second so if you
want to implement a little stack machine
or something that's all well and good to
push and pop values but we have random
access memory we want to be able to
randomly or at least arbitrarily access
our memory so let's see how you can
address specific memory addresses as
well let's just put some 64 bits the
values into our si on our di and then we
see the move instruction again so move
instructions can be used for both memory
and for registers and if you see here it
has the second operand is our si so it's
going to copy from our si and all of
this is the first operand so it's going
to move into whatever that means and
what does it mean
it says Q word puto that means a quad
word pointer so a byte 8 bits is a byte
16 bits is a word 32 bits is a double
word and 64 bits is a quad word so Q
word Peter means this is a pointer to
the 64 bits
something and where is it pointing it's
pointing to our SP minus 8 so if you go
over here our SP subtract 8
you get down here so this is saying this
is the address of our SP minus 8 so 8 so
we're going to move the contents of our
si onto that memory address so it looks
exactly like when we pushed the thing
but we now explicitly put it at exactly
that address so we could have put it at
any address really the add instruction
also supports having one of the operands
be a memory address so it's exactly the
same expression as we saw here for a
pointer to a 64-bit value at this
location take that add it to our dua and
as we saw before and we'll just store it
in the first operand so our di is 2 2 2
2 2 3 3 3 3 from here add it together
and put five five five five five five
five five five in our di so if we we're
in c or c plus this is how a local
variable on the stack looks like so this
is how it would look like exactly if you
had a long l equals 3 3 3 3 3 in your
syllabus or whatever then this is how it
would look like so before we continue I
want to say a few things about register
sizes so when the original 8086 came out
that was a 16-bit architecture with ax
BX CX etc registers they also gave us
the option to only address the lower
half with a low and a H for the high
part of ax so if you put something into
Al that's actually the same as ax just
it's just using the lower half and a H
is using the high half of it so it's
actually the same physical register in
there just different ways of addressing
parts of it then the 386 came along with
32 bits EAX you can still use the
smaller ones and finally AMD came along
with the 64 one a 6-4 bit one and then
we got our ax etc but you can still put
things in the lower parts here so those
of you who know me know I like CP post
quizzes I have a site
see poppy quit org so here's today
today's simple post quiz how big is an
int that's the correct answer yes it is
it has a slice that's that's correct
for one number so it turns out the only
requirement in the standard of CNC boss
is it has to be 16 bits or more I used
to think it had to be 7 but it turns out
it has to be at least 16 it has int has
to be at least as big as char and char
has to be 16 yeah oh the short chasm in
the a short story yeah it has to be at
least as big as short and actually I
think I think actually in a short has to
be 16 doesn't it yeah
anyway um on my computer what's what's
int to be on on or or nor normal x86 64
machine how big is an int um my machine
yeah 32 bits so when they went from 32
to 64 bits I didn't want to change the
size of int so it's still 32 bits so
this 64 bit thing corresponds to a
signed or unsigned long and you can put
a signed or unsigned int here so in the
round so in short in here and a signed
or unsigned or just plain char in these
ones so let's do a skip back this
example we just did let's do exactly the
same example but with smaller register
sizes so let's use the 32 bit variants
so we have we're still is playing the
fool RSI and RDI but let's use the 32
bit ones so ESI and EDI and those you
see a lot because in this kind of our
default go to data type so you see ESI
on EDI a lot so let's see what happens
when you use those well we move three
three three into our ESI which is the
lower half of our si 2 2 2 2 into EDI
the lower half of our di and then we're
gonna put one our registers into memory
and now we're using D word Twitter
double word pointer not a quad word
pointer because it's now it's only 32
bits
register so this is a 32-bit register so
let's use a 32-bit address RSP - 4 so it
goes in here so we only needed four
bytes for the int so we saved off the
memory and then we can add it just like
before we can add whatever is on this
address to EDI so we end up with five
five five five five yeah
yes they should yeah
thank you so that's referring to these
here should be three three three instead
so now we can read and writes both lungs
and int to memory but that's not enough
we also want to have more data we want
to erase and erase are nice also because
we get to see a bit more advanced memory
addressing it's a good motivating
example for that so let's just put some
values in memory so RSP - 8 gets 1 1 1 1
then RSP - 2 6 - 4 - 2 so now we have
some bytes in memory assembly doesn't
have any time yeah I use the word here
now so just because I don't want the
memory to grow too big I'm using shorts
so word is 16 bits so then we save some
space on the slides and see some other
register sizes but assembly doesn't have
types these are just bytes in memory so
assembly doesn't remember that I put a
16-bit value there is just bytes in
memory they could be anything so these
could be 8 bytes they could be probably
what we want to use them for for short
they could be one long they could be
some part of a string or a network
packet or a class or a structure really
they can be anything but we're going to
treat them as an array of four shorts
and array arrays are like they're almost
pointers right so if you want to do
something with an array you want a
pointer to the first element so let's
say it would be useful to put a pointer
to the beginning of the array in our
register so let's say we want to put it
in
RDI so how do we find that address well
we already saw the square bracket
operation thing we could do RSP minus 8
so our space here this the stack pointer
here's our value or a first value in the
array then you can use the le.a
instruction which is the load effective
address instruction very handy thing it
will compute the address just like we
saw it was doing here but instead of
dereferencing the value it will just
give you the address and put that into
RDI so now we have a pointer to the
beginning of the array and we can start
using it for something so let's say we
want okay yeah
I don't I think you have to put the
square brackets for this index to be
correct yeah yes so say we want to get
at the fourth element in the array what
you do you have a pointer to the
beginning you have to skip past the
element one two and three
they're both both two bytes long they're
shorts so we take 3 times 2 is 6 so we
can get to our di plus 6 and get the
fourth element in the array then we can
move it into for instance a X just to
show some different sizes again a X is
the lower 16 bits of re X but we don't
want to hard-code the array index in our
assembly code we want to be able to
maybe change where we're pointing to him
maybe we want to be able to iterate
through the array so it would be really
useful to have the array index in
another register so let's use RSI as the
index register and say we want the first
element of the array so the first
element is index 0
let's put 0 into RSI and now we can see
a bit more advanced addressing here so
Rd is still the base pointer then you
have the index and slice off short
basically so if you want to get at the
RSI element you have to multiply it by
to the size of charge to compute the
address so 0 times 2 is 0 so we're
getting the element at index 0 we're
getting 1 1 1 1 1 but now we have
parameterised 8 right this this exact
line can now take the index from a
register so let's increment our index or
index was zero we increment it with the
increment instruction now it's 1 then we
can use exactly the same instruction to
do base pointer plus index times so I
saw the element and then we can move
that into a X so now we get to instead
and now we have generalized table way to
access memory right up by the base
pointer and the index and that's kind of
begging for being used with like
conditionals or loops or something like
that so
let's look at conditionals we want to
have we want to write an if statement
which takes two numbers checks if the
first one is greater in that case it
stores true if the first one is not
greater it source false quite simple but
in assembly we don't have if or switch
or else or anything like nice like that
we have comparisons and go to basically
but gotas are considered great so let's
see what we can do with go to let's move
some values into registers are the INRs
Ayano 3 and 2 then we can compare them
and nothing happens when I execute to
the compare it just compares it doesn't
return you anything it just checks
various properties of comparing these
numbers and just stores it away in some
flags in a Flags register on the next
line I can do a conditional jump so I
can do jump if greater in jg is for jump
if greater so it will check those flags
that were set on the previous line and
and see well was it greater are di was
greater than 3 greater than 2 so yes I
jump where do I jump to a label and this
is how labels look so I jump to the
label and we want to store it true
because the first number was greater so
let's move 1 for true into our ax and
now our a X contains crew if it was the
other way around if we had to in our di
and 3 quickly stopped working yeah go to
in our di 3 and RSI compare them nothing
happens jump if greater was our di
larger than 3 it was not so we don't
jump we just fall through we fall
through into here the next line we store
false in our ax but now we have to be
careful so we don't fall through down
here right the labels aren't protecting
this in any way so we have to do an
additional jump to get out of the if to
avoid the other condition and you might
notice here that like this was kind of
our else block a false thing and this
was our if block the true thing so often
you'll see that the else block is above
if block there's a bunch of comparison
operators all right there's one
comparison operators operator and
there's a bunch of jump conditional
jumps so compare up one up two we'll
compare these two and then all of these
will check the results so if they were
equal you can jump equal you can jump
not equal you can jump less less equal
jump greater and jump greater or equal
and I said assembly doesn't have types
so it doesn't care what the type of a
byte is in memory or in a register or
whatever but comparisons are different
right you have a bit pattern that can
either be a positive number or if it's a
sign type it can be a negative number so
the inter you have to choose do you want
a signed or unsigned comparison so we
have some unsigned comparison operators
as well and well greater and less we're
taking so let's use below and above
instead so here are the corresponding
ones for unsigned and the way the
comparison works is it just subtracts
the second operand from the first that's
basically all it does if there was if
they were equal the result is zero it
doesn't store the result anamur but it
stores the fact that it was zero it sets
the zero flag if this was greater than
this well then it gets the subtraction
result results in a negative number and
then it sets the sign flag so what these
two are just checking the flags that's
the comparison left in the flags
register
okay now we have variables erase memory
addressing conditionals we also want
loops and assembly doesn't have if a
Nelson anything like that of course it
doesn't have while or for or do or
anything like that either
we still have comparisons and our go-to
is though so we can implement a for
using that so let's say we want to
iterate over over over a value we want
to iterate from one so let's use our CX
as our loop index set a to one and we
want to accumulate a value in our a X so
let's initialize that to zero then
there's a label and then we compare our
CX two three so this is our loop
termination Jackie is it three it's not
three so jump equal will not jump it was
not equal it doesn't jump it just falls
falls through and it increments our
results just to have something to do
let's just add the loop counter to our a
X then we can increment the counter so
now that's two and we unconditionally
jump to the beginning of the for loop
are we three yet
we're not free yet so we do not jump
equal keep adding our CX to our ax
increment our CX to for the next round
jump to the beginning are we three yet
yes
we're three so we jump to the end of the
for loop that's how we do a for loop and
can anyone translate this for loop in to
see yeah let's see so here's the C code
so we say int our ax equals zero for our
z x equals 1 or C X not equal to three
and then we have the plus plus RZ x then
we can go our ax plus equals r CX so
that's how you can do a for loop
so let's look at a real example not this
one it's too large let's look at a
smaller one simple sum function simplest
function I could think of really sum
function takes two integers a and B
something together and returns the
result sum of a plus B just return a
plus B let's just bring all of that code
on the right-hand side it's it's a bit
it's not too long let's bring it into
our little slide where emulator so
here's all of our assembly code that we
got from I happen to use GCC 9.1 but I
can't imagine this would change very
much with other versions so the first
thing to think about with a function is
how do you get the arguments into the
function that's the first thing you have
to do so it turns out there's a thing
called a calling convention I'm on a Mac
I wrote the presentation on my Linux
computer both of those use the system v
amd64
calling convention the calling
convention will specify among other
things how do you get stuff in and out
of functions and Microsoft has their own
calling convention it's very similar to
the system v1 and it says the first
couple of integers you can just stick
them in some registers that we agree on
so it says the two first integers
integers to go should go in RDI and RSI
so whoever called the sum function would
first put the arguments 2 and 3 that it
wants to sum into those registers then
call us because then we can just go and
pick them up from there then we start
our function the first thing we do is to
push a register on to the stack we're
pushing our BP and the reason for that
is and you can see we push it here and
then we pop it at the end and that's
because it's our obligation by the
calling convention to not destroy our BP
so whoever called us we're probably
using our BP for something so let's make
sure if we overwrite it we have
restore it and we are going to overwrite
it on the next line so let's push that
first then we move our sp remember the
stack pointer we move our SP into our VP
the reason we do that this you're gonna
see in all functions when you look at
them and compiler explorer it always
does this it puts a copy of RSP into RB
P and that's because in many many cases
we are going to start messing about with
the stack pointer we might be pushing
and popping stuff we might call other
functions we might need to change our SP
so it's very nice if we in the beginning
of the function we just make a copy here
this is called the base pointer then we
have a base pointer that points to the
beginning of our part of the stack this
is our stack frame our stuff and then we
can do all this relative addressing here
relative to our VP instead of our RSP in
case that changes in this function we
don't mess about with our SP it doesn't
change but it seems that most compilers
will always do this anyway so what does
GCC do okay first a disclaimer I didn't
write this code GCC wrote this code so
if you have any issues with it take it
up with the GCC what's what is doing
well we got the two arguments here in
our do an RSI it wants to move those
into memory for some reason so it moved
them into RB p -4 and 8 so we got them
copied in here and here and this is
actually good because these are our
function arguments there are L values we
they now have an address we can take the
red dress we can inspect them in a
debugger they are actual variables in
memory rather than just paying some
values in registers so if you're doing a
debug buildin I guess this is fine then
Jesus he wants to copy them back into
registers so it uses EDX and EAX to copy
them back into and we add edx to EAX so
3 plus 2 equals 5
and then we have to pop our appear
remember not to step on our callers toes
so we pop that and we return and return
just sets the instruction pointer back
to whoever called us the missing piece
of the puzzle is how do we get the
return value out of our function and up
to our caller and again this is the
calling convention telling us that if
you're returning a single int I just put
it in our ax and then the caller will
after getting return back and just look
in re X and expect you to have left the
package in our ax and then finally we
return so if anyone thought that that
was a quite cumbersome way to add two
values I think both me and GCC agree
with you so we can put in some compiler
options so let's try all - let's try a
one so on even on our one it decides to
do this optimization so it's now a
one-liner that we just do a one-liner
and return remember le a load effective
address so this is a instruction used
for loading effective addresses so what
we are not loading any addresses why are
we using le a well it turns out that
this is something you do a lot so this
is very very fast to do arithmetic you
can do simple arithmetic in here and
again assembly has no type so if you
just give it some values we can just
pretend one of them is an address that
doesn't matter right so we just we just
kind of hijack le a to do the addition
and the nice thing as unlike the normal
add instruction which adds the result in
one of the operands we can choose where
to get the result so we can add already
IRS ID that two registers that the
calling convention gave us the values in
and put them directly into the register
where we supposed to put the result by
the calling dimension so that's a nice
little optimization that you will see a
lot so now we don't need to move
anything into memory or back again
so optimisations argued then we've seen
variables memory erase memory addressing
control flow if and for even started
looking at functions then we can move on
to the holy grail of programming
paradigms which is structured
programming okay let's see what happens
in a full function so here we have our
little sum function again it's almost
the same as before takes two integers a
and B sum sum together but multiplies
them by two before returning so times to
function just takes its argument returns
its multiplied by two so we have our
function a plus B pass it through times
two and then return yeah I'm cool I'll
copy all of that all of this assembly
code it's now starting to look a bit big
but most of it we've actually seen
before so it's not going to be so bad
we'll put all that into our slide where
emulator again and we're going to need a
bit more memory because we're going to
call some functions and stuff so I just
added another column of memory it's
still just sequential memory just going
down here a zero and then continuing
again 9f oops and continuing down here
so it's just to make it all fit on the
flights so first we push our BP we've
seen this before then we move our SP
into our BP again to have like a stable
base pointer to do our addressing
relative to this time we need it this
time we're going to change our SP so we
had to make this copy of our SP because
we're going to mess about with it and
why are we going to change the top of
the stack well the sometimes to function
is going to call this other function and
when we call that function
that function is going to start using
the stack pointer and saying okay
everything from the stack pointer on I
can use so we have to make sure we first
bump that out of the way so that we have
our own part of memory that we can write
you and not get overwritten by by
whoever we call so then we can see RSP
got bumped all the way down here to this
place and now everything is as exactly
like it was in our first time function
we got the two arguments by the colon
convention in our di and our si GCC
wants to put them in memory and then put
them back again and then it was the
addition the ex edx and that in EAX
exactly like in our previous some
function so EA x is 3 and we add edx so
it's 5 now it's our turn to call a
function so now it's our turn to think
about the calling end of the calling
convention so we have to make sure the
single integer argument that we're going
to pass to the x 2 function has to be in
EDI so we have our result a plus B is an
ax we need to get that into EDI before
calling our function and then we call we
just transfer control down here and
again push our BP move our BP our SP
we've seen those now many times we also
see in this we take the EDI the argument
we got put it into memory so we have a
proper local variable and put it back
into a register and even here on o0 GCC
figured let's not do
that's what x - let's just add it to
itself instead because that's faster so
we add the ax to a ax so 5 plus 5 equals
a then we pop our BP as we always do and
we return so now we're
about to leave the outer function and we
have to make sure the result is in EAX
because that's what the : Convention
tells us to do well it turns out we are
just returning whatever we got from The
Times to function so here we're just
returning that and that's that value
happens to already be in EAX
so we don't have to do anything we can
just leave and the live instruction is a
new one we haven't seen before like
we're used to if you're returning from a
function so far we've been used to
popping our BP and returning this time
however we have messed about with the
stack pointer so the leave instruction
will first restore the stack pointer if
I click on the right screen it will yeah
it will restore the stack pointer by
copying our BP back into it and then it
will do the proper BP that we've seen
all the times so far and we return from
the function so again that seemed like a
lot of work what happens if we add some
optimization here turns out a 1 is
enough doesn't help to put one more so
let's first look at x 2 it's supposed to
multiply its arguments so it did that
very quickly by just doing ad r di r di
or EDI EDI it turns out that we can also
use the load effective address here just
to take this sum and stick it in the
other register in one operation so we
don't have to first do the addition and
move it into our ax or anything like
that so what about this sometimes to
function it gets it or its arguments in
EDI and ESI so let's add those together
into EDI so now a plus B is in EDI and
now it's actually in lines all of the
times to function in here so just
basically copy/paste the implementation
of this one in here so adjust the times
to think
directly here without having a function
call and then we return
so again optimizations to help so if we
go back to our first example yeah sure
probably because then it wouldn't be
visible outside the compilation units oh
yeah sure Thanks yeah yeah so the reason
it keeps it is because if you compile
this compilation unit and you link it to
someone else then even if you inline the
times to this signature still needs to
be here in the object file so that you
can link to it and call it from some
other compilation unit but if you make
it static it doesn't have external
linkage you can't link to it so we can
just remove it
was that a question or a statement okay
yeah so the comet is like why is it
using our di plus or di and not EDI plus
e SI e EDI plus ESI and the hypothesis
is that it might because be because le I
needs a 4-bit address that sounds
possible I'm not sure does anyone know
oh it doesn't matter because if you if
you write to e si it's going to zero out
the upper part so if it didn't zero out
it could be that's that there would be
something else in the top but well we
only store it in EAX anyway so yeah
sounds like a possible theory yeah so
back to the original I promised you that
at the end of the talk we were going to
understand all of this assembly code
it's not the most advanced program I've
seen but it does have functions for
loops assignments returning stuff
calling other functions if statements it
has like all the programming basics and
that's kind of the goal of this talk is
to cover the basics to give you like a
fundamental understanding that's that
you can build on so let's see I'm not
going to go through everything in detail
but if you look at this code after the
talk sit down and you will recognize
everything from us we talked about so
let's look at the computer function push
our BP move our BP RSP we've seen that
that's the usual preamble don't destroy
our BP take a backup the stay off the
stack pointer in the back in the base
pointer so we can do addressing relative
to that keyword footer means this is the
32 bits thing we're addressing in memory
EDI on ESI why those registers because
those were the parameters they go into
those registers by the calling
convention and then we have a for loop
so in our for loop were just
decrementing be until and as long as
it's larger than zero so B has been
moved from here into here so we can
compare that to zero if it was equal the
for loop is done so then we can jump
down a bit so this is our end for down
here if it wasn't the equal we'll do the
body of the function so we'll move a and
B into these registers add B to a and
move the result back into memory and
subtract one from B so this is the minus
minus B in the for loop and then we jump
to the beginning of the for loop again
so this is things we've already seen and
then it finally moves the result into
EAX why does it move it into EAX because
that's where the calling convention
tells us results should be we pop our BP
to restore it and return call her again
the preambles going to go through that
setting aside some space on the stack so
whenever you see sub RSP something it
means let's let's reserve some space on
the stack for ourselves and again with
the ESI EDI so we have this literal
values 1 & 3 so let's put those as the
arguments let's call the function on the
function returns the result will be in
EAX let's put that into a local variable
so this will now be our I over here then
we compare it to 9 because we're going
to check if it's less than 10 so we
decided to do that with a compared to 9
and jump greater and then it will move
the results in here if it was less than
10 then we return I and otherwise we
just go down to the end and return 10
you see here then we do the leave we
need to leave now because we did we did
mess about with the stack pointer so
we'll leave will restore the stack
pointer and pop our BP and then return
will we
turn us back to our recorder so now we
have everything we need to understand
all of that code so the goal here was to
mainly like if you can have very simple
code you can actually understand the
output the other goal is to have a
fundamental understanding of how these
things work so when you paste your code
you're going to have some instructions
here that you don't understand good
thing here to do then is just hover over
it and then you get a short description
of what that instruction is doing and
you can go and search for it online and
find more information but hopefully
after this talk then you have at least
some framework to help you understand
those results so some tips if you want
to use compiler Explorer for your own
code is to actually show the slides
hover the instruction to see a
description then google it and make a
local standalone reproduction first so
if you have codes that which includes
lots of other stuff and calls function
try to get everything into one CPP file
that doesn't include any non-standard
stuff maybe I have some refactoring
tools that can help you or than else
copy paste is good just try to mash
everything into one CPP file and remove
everything you don't need and then paste
it and it's easier to read sometimes you
want to look at a specific feature of
the purpose it's often helpful to use
instead of complicated types so in many
cases it's a lot easier to see if you
just use an int and set of like some
really complicated stuff unless it has
of course side-effects that are
important to you and don't try it out on
your full project right
don't inline your entire thing and place
it it's mostly useful to look at very
like specific things that you want robot
and yeah I also also wanted to ask if
there are any other
tips from the audience for use in
compiler Explorer Jason Turner might
know something about this yeah yeah
that's that's that's a good thing yeah
put it on Twitter or Stack Overflow or
something that's also also possible yeah
you didn't have many questions during
the talk so there's some time left for
questions so any other questions yeah
yes that was I was trying not to
complicate stuff but yeah so beyond
caught me cheating a bit especially in
this example so when I just step back if
you yeah so when I call here and then
later I return down here so how how does
it know where to return to so what it
does it will actually push the
instruction pointer on to the stack when
it calls and when you return it will get
that value back to know where it's going
to and in that way I can you can call as
many functions as you will until the
stack is full so yeah leave we'll do the
pop rbp thing that we've been doing all
the time but in addition it's gonna
restore the stack pointer because we we
subtract 16 from the decide pointer here
and then we have to make sure we add 16
back before we go out so the way it
restores it is to take well we we did
take a backup of RSP into RB P here
right so it's gonna copy our BP back
into RSP and then pop our VP so if we go
down yeah here yeah so the first thing
it does copy our BP into our SP so our
SP is now back where it was and then pop
our BP
and there should have been an
instruction pointer at at least on the
stack in between here but then I would
have to add yet another column of memory
and my slide would be even more
unreadable so I skipped that one any
other questions question let's optimize
it yep
it does change quite a lot so what does
it do it takes the first arguments of a
puts it right into the result thing and
then it tests if B is equal to itself so
this computes a bit radical and yeah so
this is kind of like compare I don't
know what just us yeah so test for 0 if
it was 0 we jump to the end of the for
loop and then we can just return because
we already have the results in here a is
AE ax is whatever a was if not then
we're going to keep adding ESI which is
be keeping adding it onto a pour it out
onto the result and do B - - and yeah
here's another thing I said that compare
is basically a subtract which doesn't
store the results so here's an actual
subtract and this is quite nice because
then you don't have to first subtract
and then then do a comparison after you
can just jump if not equal so subtract 1
from you so I if it reached 0 it will
set the zero flag so we can just test
that that down here instead of doing and
doing an actual extra compared and Coler
ah that's nice movie x7 that's
everything so it will do some constant
propagation and inlining and stuff and
just yeah return seven
and again if we would make the computer
function static so we can't reach it
from other compression units this entire
thing yes pretty nice so yeah yeah any
other questions yeah do the better thing
to measure because it's like this is
what the compiler says to the CPU like
here's CPU do these things and the CPU
is going to say yeah yeah sure and then
it's gonna go do something completely
different right it's gonna reorder stuff
the branch prediction and you get like
cache things so you can't really see
okay are we trashing the cache or not
like all of those things are very
important and the algorithmic complexity
so I would at least not like use this as
the truth for performance but you can
very often be useful to get some more
knowledge about things so I think Matt's
got balls
he said his his motivation for creating
compiler Explorer when it was just a
local command-line tool we had was he
wanted to check when they introduced
range based for loops so are they gonna
do are they gonna be more expensive than
just for I equals 0 etc and then you
could do both versions in here and you
can see the assembly acts exactly the
same and then you can quickly check
different compilers and in that case you
can trust well ok the range base for
loop is fine he could use it in his high
frequency trading or whatever he was
doing at the time so for those things
it's nice and for other things it's just
handy or you're curious I did put out a
tweet some a month or two ago saying
what are some cool things you learn on
compadres program and I got no replies
and then then Matt got ball treated
tweeted it from the compadre store
accounts and then all of the yet more
zero replies came in but hopefully you
can actually use it for something
useful so I use it at work a little
while ago I was trying an approach where
instead of using enums and switches I
was I wanted to use bronze so I would
Lisa variants instead of an enum value I
would have several varieties and see
like how is that gonna work is it going
to be enlightened as well as enums and
switches and it turned out that even
with all - it was doing function calls
to state visit and I don't know how its
implemented or anything but like well
the elements which case was just like
move some stuff in here and return the
other one was doing function calls and
everything and I thought well maybe
that's not the best approach even the
white I thought that was really clever
so whether you can do stuff like that
okay I found it useful to test if
something is worth going through with
for example I have an ID that I think
the compiler will be able to inline and
I can run it in company do we think up
I'll explore test my ID see yeah it's
plausible so I make the effort in the
program then it's really nice if you see
that like you can open another tab one
minute left so I'll do that ad not here
we go
add new compiler so here we can compare
to GCC 9.2 or we can like see if we can
find clang I think it's somewhere at the
top see what clank-clank drunk to us and
let's see give it the same options yeah
so then then you can compare so like if
they've done beyond ancestor all the way
all the compilers he is interested in do
the same thing then that's a good sign
it isn't
yeah yeah yeah so it's it's a good way
to test if it's possible let's be honest
and then you can can measure okay
that's times up so thank you
[Applause]